je veux que ou 31 décembre 2019 monde
est apte à le truc complètement dingue
[Musique]
bonne année bonne année à tous bonne
santé joie bonheur le package complet
pour 2019
on va faire un point l'idée de cette
vidéo c'est de faire un petit point sur
ce qui s'est passé en 2010 8 points
rapides
regardez les objectifs pour 2010 9 mai
au final voir avec vous ce qui est bien
ce que j'ai réussi en 2018 que j'ai raté
ce que j'ai aussi raté les jo 2018 puis
voir un petit peu la ligne conductrice
pour 2019 j'espère que j'ai passé de
bonnes fêtes
bon réveillon vous avez bien profité et
donc je vois sur les prix de bonnes
résolutions parfaitement c'est pas trop
mon truc les résolutions parce que en
règle générale je les prends deux jours
après ces trois jours après c'est mort
il n'ya pas du tout de résolutions par
contre les objectifs et ça c'est pas
l'important début 2018 j'avais pris on
avait un objectif l'objectif était
d'atteindre le palier fin de mai 18 des
100 mille abonnés vous est arrivé un
mois en avance ça c'est franchement pas
rita cool pile poil le jour mon
anniversaire donc ça c'est tout voilà
juste incroyable merci merci à vous tous
merci à vous tous d'être là toujours
plus nombreuses et toujours plus
nombreux en gros on doit être à peu près
cent seize mille et quelques sur la
chaîne donc ça c'est franchement
franchement franchement hyper cool ça
c'était l'objectif pour la fin d'année
donc je suis hyper content l'objectif
c'était aussi que machines deviennent
rentables et que je puisse en vivre
c'est aujourd'hui le cas donc ça c'est
un point extrêmement positif je suis
consacré à 100% sur ma chaîne
aujourd'hui dombasle a fait très très
très heureux donc ça c'est vraiment le
point réussie pour cette année il ya un
deuxième point que j'avais pris une
deuxième bonne résolution de travaux le
deuxième objectif qu'elle s'était fixée
début 2018 c'était d'avoir une chaîne
secondaire sûr de la stratégie youtube
c'est un truc que j'avais commencé à
faire un petit peu sur l'été 2010 elle
je trouvais ça cool essayé de donner des
clés à la dé des personnes qui voulaient
se lancer
non pas que j'avais atteint lé sommet
que j'ai trouvé la légitimité pour faire
mais que des trois trucs que j'avais
pigé
l'idée c'était effectivement de le
partager avec vous et j'ai donc créé en
début d'année
cette chaîne de stratégie et youtube
et malheureusement c'est pas du tout du
tout du tout du tout le temps de
réaliser une seule vidéo de la publier
et ça c'est vraiment point de regrets
donc pour l'instant cette chaîne est en
stand by
elle va le rester pendant probablement
longtemps je veux pas fermer parce que
j'ai pas le temps tout simplement j'ai
pas le temps donc de faire cette chaîne
l'a donc ça voilà ça c'est un peu le
constat d'échec sur l'année 2018 on vous
dit rien pierre un constat d'échec
mais voilà j'ai pas eu le temps donc ça
va c'était vraiment les deux points
principaux pour l'année
donc c'est une sacrée aventure il s'est
passé plein de choses ont commencé
l'année dernière au csa las vegas une
plein plein de rencontres à un peu
impromptue le fait de rencontrer le
président emmanuel macron c'est assez
surprenant également même si je sais
qu'il est décrié je ne pas pas de
politique c'était juste une rencontre
ensuite le mwc barcelone il y fera
quelques mois plus tard il est plein de
belles rencontres plein d'opportunités
et l'année au final s'est extrêmement
bien passé et je suis très heureux donc
j'espère 2019
on va se passer au moins dans la même
ligne directrice avec plein de beaux
succès alors je vous donne les objectifs
pour 2019 vous allez voir comme je me
suis fixé un objectif au 1er janvier
2018 vont filer en 1er janvier 2019
je veux que au 31 décembre 2019
on est atteint le truc complètement
dingue de 500 mille abonnés ça paraît
complètement fou retournant j'ai réussi
à gagner cent mille abonnés l'idée
maintenant c'est de gagner quatre cent
mille abonnés en un an
ça paraît fou l'objectif n'est pas gagné
d'avancé mais c'est ça qui fait qu'un
challenge est beau c'est quand on se
donne des objectifs on fait tout pour
réussir
il va falloir bosser sur le contenu
amélioré contenu amélioré la forme j'ai
plein d'idées plein de choses que je
veux faire donc voilà il ya plein plein
plein de projets pour cette nouvelle
année je suis super content j'espère que
ça va me plaire
et franchement je vous invite vraiment à
marquer tout en bas en commentaire dites
moi ce qu'il vous plaît aujourd'hui dans
le format actuel ce qui ne vous plaît
pas ce que vous voudriez
voir quels sont les types de vidéos que
vous aimeriez retrouver le plus ce
qu'est ce qui vous plaît vous déplaît
vous aidez pas vous remarquez tout en
bas l'idée ce n'est pas de faire un
achat joue dans son celi 17 discuter
façon constructive pour permettre à moi
d'avoir votre retour d'améliorer un peu
tout ça et ça c'est pas important pour
un peu de regret également j'en ai déjà
parlé dans la vidéo des 100000 à bosse
et le vrai manque de temps pour pouvoir
répondre prendre du temps à tous les
commentaires j'essaie de le faire au
maximum mais je suis un peu débordé pour
tout vous dire c'est un peu a publié une
vidéo jours avec plein de commentaires
plus de commentaires sur les vieilles
vidéos qui arrive en gros ça me fait
dans un but quantité juge pas de fait
entre 300 à 500 commentaires jours
malheureusement j'ai pas le temps tous
les regarde et il y en a je passe à côté
plus tous les messages privés sur
twitter sur facebook plus les toutefois
je suis complètement en âge les jeux de
ce tournage complètement
j'ai vraiment essayé de trouver un
process plus simple pour voilà vous
répondre au mieux dans les meilleures
conditions
donc ça va ça n'a pas vraiment amélioré
aussi en 2019
et puis surtout j'ai un nouvel à gros
objectif est aussi complètement taré
mais qui est vraiment dans la même ligne
droite que ce que je fais actuellement
je lance tout de suite une deuxième
chaîne
alors je sais vous allez me dire qu'est
ce qui fait que dans une deuxième chaîne
il a déjà réussi à face un film de
stratégie youtube en arrière ouais mais
celle là c'est vraiment un peu la même
chose que je fais aujourd'hui sauf que
au lieu de le faire en français j'avais
le faire en anglais c'est une chaîne us
une chaîne américaine
je vais faire exactement la même chose à
quelque chose près d'arrêter de vendre
du contenu que contenu un peu différente
c'est pour ça que je pourrai mutualiser
un peu de contenu notamment au niveau
des animations de pas mal de choses mais
je garde bien évidemment ma chaîne
française qui m'achètent principal
qu'est la chaîne que je développe et la
chaîne sur laquelle on s'est rencontrés
mais je créé en parallèle ma chaîne us
d'ailleurs je vous invite à rejoindre
s'ils voulaient filer un petit coup de
main je vous ai mieux le lien en bas
dans la description vous pouvez venir
vous inscrire ça me permet de la lancée
que ça évite de partir de zéro parce que
là tout de suite
elle est à zéro donc comme ça on lance
un peu la machine ça me permet de valade
lors des encouragements d'avancé donc si
vous êtes ok allez vous inscrire et
comme ça vous pouvez me dire également
ce que vous en pensez frontières faire
parler dans la langue de shakespeare là
c'est obligé on va parler holding liste
at-il faillite voilà donc gérer ses
goûts
gros gros gros challenge aussi pour
cette nouvelle année
et vous quelles sont vos bonnes
résolutions est ce que vous avez pris
des bonnes résolutions pour l'année 2019
est-ce que vous avez surtout mis des
objectifs que ce soit en termes
familiale en termes professionnels avoir
un enfant être plus sage faire du sport
avoir un plan de carrière qu'est ce que
vous vous êtes fixé comme objectif pour
vous marquez tout ça en barrant
commentaire chez les hommes ayant ce
moment je filme avec un boîtier qui
n'est pas à moi donc je vais rester un
peu plus sur un plan peut un peu figé
plus jazz 5 pour le moment donc voilà va
falloir que je retrouve un parce que
d'ici quelques jours je pars à new york
et j'ai plein de choses à faire là-bas
plein de tests après on s'envole
ensemble pour las vegas
donc ça va marquer le début 2019 avec
des trucs complètement hallucinant donc
on va s'éclater
voilà donc je vous invite à bien
évidemment rester connecté on va suivre
cette actu de très près ailleurs plein
de jeunes choisis faire couler filiation
vous remarquez bien sûr une fois de plus
tout ce que vous voulez en bas en
commentaire merci à vous merci merci
merci du fond du coeur d'être là
nombreuses nombreux je vous invite à me
rejoindre sur ma chaîne us le lien je
vous le dis est en bas et vous donne
rendez vous dès demain je vous embrasse
et encore une excellente année à vous
toutes et à vous tous ciao
[Musique]